you know in some ways League of Legends
is a simple game when it comes to
champions you have to pick what everyone
else does
and just try to play the game better
than they do of course there are counter
picks of course there's the odd fringe
lock-in but at the end of the day if you
want to go truly off-script if you want
to pick a truly off met a champion well
let's just say it's risky
you could get rekt dumped stirred
destroyed or everything could work out
in your favor and that crazy pocket pick
could deliver you and your team to glory
that's why this week on best of we're
focusing on the craziest off meta
champion picks that actually worked and
a few that didn't but let's start this
video off on a positive note shall we so
they're targeting more ignore as a
player rather than actually give the
support the Leona this makes so much
sense or you can't do anything while
they try to get to the front already
ignite goes down immediately no flash
forward but the deal comes out they turn
to wall fizz bank because I can get back
into the fight just a hunch over a stove
johan sama one more shot as wolf wants
the glitter lands
pull the trigger
everyone always
here comes bachelor 2 to get a visa to
party
the shield will miss Mattia they want to
get more hoody still no flash I saw the
best older
they are putting these on a silver
platter is going to cause damage here
Lulu would be whoa that would be nice
but I I'd be surprised
I'd be happy and it's counting down
Baker it could play anything Wow it's
best to eat Baker like that's got to be
fake you're playing the master you what
is going on this is so hard to pull off
for SK Telecom it is going to be amazing
if they are able to make this work
Baker's like you know what
I played Victor too many times I played
the same champion too many times I need
a new one again finger doesn't care
about your counter picks you're good or
bad matchups they could just plays what
he wants to play but oh they're going
ambition is the alpha strike whoa we're
going full solo killing here flash over
the wall from Baker bomb arts can
actually use this an ultimate here can
they make a pulp on this they get the
Sun faker coming in use this at ultimate
Peter comes ambition they're gonna turn
on them though faker gets the damage oh
not quite enough because of the position
reversal now he does get enough gets a
double kill shy looks like he's gonna be
able to get a bitter event always been
successful on and really mentality for
balls is something that always keeps in
the game you put him on any champion
listen no no aah that was on that that
was on the score sheet you can see the
sheet they're being handed off to the
rap saying we're done with this now
thank you we'll be fine with Teemo feels
that they can take what they need here
and make the fight still happen in their
favor they're getting good poke damage
not even good poke damage on two balls
he's gonna keep him there for the fight
he is almost locking down five members
they don't want to move they're all
magnetically attracted to him and dyrus
is the focus for cloud nine right now
this could give wildturtle the rest of
the team enough time to do damage but
cloud 9 is just too tanky team solomid
picked nunu they picked a heavy control
composition as we look at this so if
they get caught in a full teamfight that
don't move they're not taking advantage
of his mobility edge since they lost
that with Teemo then cloud 9 you just
collapse it around
I actually flashed in from behind the
fight here to just pop wildturtle as he
was trying to do this fight and once
that happened the fight was over gooks
in would've definitely thrown them back
into it had that chillers left a good
stunt staying on course right now it's
like I will find whoa that was some big
damn it why you got hurts this is a guy
who's played for different roles
competitively over his extremely long
rear of it
yeah just three at one entire split but
for game of world's 2017 group stages
I think the spiciest pick/ban so far we
can safely say she doesn't need to
flashing that situation at all right now
meanwhile though every time there is a
fight on the other side there push to
turn it comes the paranoia it comes lead
by and down goes so as Levi here is
probably the most effective guy in the
entire game so far spell shield fear
comes out red buff is taking cabs
running fourth light will be by should
be on the furthest edge on Springer
burning him out fakers LeBlanc one of
the best yes yeah he locks it in for
Game five faker has never lost with
leblanc
on the competitive stage weld and oh and
now he has it here this explosive
Alistair has already been locked in for
the support mauka has been looking for
the top lane and now Morgana is being
picked by EDG and you told me before the
tournament started we would see pig on
the block first of all in the last game
butane ever link jungle and Morgana mid
laner
protocol you insane poor Ghana is a
great mid game but is not able to take
down carries in the late game there
roaming kill strategy is really strong
and
by Mako use the minion then soul
shackles faker there's gonna be clear
love coming up as well faker gets to
mimic there and he's gonna be able to
get out alive that team composition was
it specifically drafted to counter
LeBlanc in every way shape and form
tanks spell shields left right and
center lots of magic resist and it just
shows how hard it is to beat this guy's
LeBlanc flowing mane of fabulous Fabio
NER you get a job is like one of the
hair products at L'Oreal after is it
says private short is worth it oh my god
speaking of which and that is going to
be two signature champions locked in
palace knocks Luna the anivia fakira
hunter percent win rates throughout the
regular season didn't play it all that
much in the brand support bollock red
sometimes you just gotta use the flesh
get yourself out of it that is gonna
spell the [ __ ] here in the mid lane
first one I clean calling is gonna come
Annie's pretty optimistic as here takes
another one doesn't
let great gets revenge bins are being
set yes nice looking for back stories
him up into the a liquid she leaves the
one that crap said that was a beautiful
Pig the lease it exploit a miracle get
shop way for that's only one target
eager stay off the queue
well there is there from you've heard
the love that's not so keen on the
xerath here for no I would be very
worried about getting a run down by
sever's Swiss legate pick tf2 that yeah
that's a good point
definitely a blind pick TF for power of
evil first one we're gonna see here in
the tournament you can do some pretty
much and okay hold on wait a minute
alright so we got a lock and LeBlanc
just jungle to you Langston already know
what to think about this all right I
have an inkling
Oh what's going on good soon as I saw it
but I can't be like I got this there's
there's a guy come on set this Korean
jungle history player yeah he went over
there he plays smash ze all-time in what
he gets when he doesn't get Master Yi is
he goes with his TF jungle I'm really
curious how many people are gonna try
and ring us with such fate and not know
how to do this like this is actually
really impressive the spot he's standing
so that it's fake leashing back to him
and really not hitting them at all it's
er easy is that circle o stone actually
going down flat
the kill so right now we're gonna
probably see their eighty carried choice
and their toppling choice would he go
with the dog oh man
have you seen this matchup that nastas
dog I haven't seen her recently
dyrus gets hit up this might be the time
now he starts to teleport he goes in
dyrus is going to have to get out with
the team he leaves the slicing Bell
storm on Science Park could easily
single-handedly win the game by himself
5454 of the clock the Nexus turret he
has minions it's going to be on to the
neck they see kind of mazing he misses
the shock wave or the sonic wave I
should say and he hits the tempest the
[ __ ] may slow the attack but it's not
on that oh my god
he is going to be able to hit it a few
last hits
[Applause]
when's the game predict the toss he had
172 by the time you got that last hit on
the nexus amazing need an OB to use his
ultimate and he wouldn't stop the push
and then could be a playmaker you can TP
down you can get these big mega gnar
alts that could perhaps turn around a
game I think that's what they're looking
for and it is going to be the Karma mid
and as I called out earlier bar Alf re
looking to get himself strong right on
to bang that's gonna be the barrier
immediately cosmic radiance as well to
the bank goes deep and it's going to be
the explosive shot to take down bang
make plays an apartment for misfits how
far he takes up first ignores there as
well as he speeds around the map to help
the team but now it's about getting max
lure out 10 they help them cosmic
radiance and Cataclysm down unto Him an
SKT get one back when it's ride it right
back retribution he'll keep on the top
side of the map because of what has fog
on the flag and drag-out quit silence
coming in from ignore and it's going to
be Hahn solid going forward knowing they
don't have peanut for this fight makers
rotated back around faked his voyage but
the crew right through the uprights and
he's going to say walk this way the
team's gonna have to meet him on the
other side the cleanse comes out
the left the rest of the team is left
wondering if there's gonna be looking
for hooks alive and healthy much more
ready not his own choice peanut goes
down consistency and confidence from
game one they kept going forward boo
they keep going forward
you know sometimes that successful off
meta pick can make you a pioneer all of
a sudden you're crazy pocket champion is
the new normal
echo do actually quite well against
Rumble once he can get to spectres cap
but when we're talking oh who has that's
the pushing lanes they actually have
done an insta lock misfortune it's been
really weird I don't care about my last
point this is an insta locked misfortune
support MF I'm just still shocked by the
fact that support misfortune is being
played in the semi-finals of the World
Championship I don't care if someone
tells you to pick a meta game champion
when you're gorilla and you're fighting
for your tournament life here against SK
Telecom t1 and you say hey it's time to
play support misfortune which means they
can play safe and play aggressive arrows
be damned you cares the two-on-two
killed for the rocks bottom yeah but if
if SK if you can fight back you will
meet so much for this series because
this is the largest bull deficit that's
20 remember gangplank is a flex pick it
can go to the mid lane I might even say
so I'll be better in the mid lane you
have a friend boy guys well I love this
pic this is like so now we know the mid
lane we're assuming that's incarnations
Vega that's gonna be this picking band
is Christmas they are so far ahead and
map pressure as well sneaky he's burning
he needs to run away incarnation that
secured to kill red carnation has 497
ability power at 22 minutes a baron as
well and they are now seating in here at
start it is down it's gonna be your will
be hard-pressed to kill this mundo ethyl
a true Corki doesn't tank bus if you're
not getting that if gravity does not
kill its in the middle don't say
anything
of course it's in the middle this is
keen but I'm stunned they let him play
it what's the new news the tank speed
slows no it works out inside the junco
quite a good choke point therefore st.
fishes as new do we he gets popped up
immediately lustboy and Stanton alright
wait low gravity is again the fight they
want wild turtle right into the middle
of the fight once again he gets popped
dyrus is jockey big though dyrus is big
but it's going to be too many members of
gravity now to focus the fight we
wondered what would happen Coby and they
got the 4v5 they wanted pushing out
lustboy to end the fight he's gonna be
able to use it out but you don't want
range oh no of course Susan Barrett is
they'll get three damage they got it he
gets hit and crushed by Keane in the
muramana tab right through everything
cake Minh is still available
the STS she was before ad carry Kenan
has to be absolutely has to be saw
earlier in morons hands in the top lane
he built a hurricane on it and later on
King and wits end
so maybe rectus will do the same builder
from a different role I mean play the
rune King Kenan cadet East opiate thing
in the bottom Lane against a big tank up
on top
achieve expect wants to try his hands on
this is this is a shocking amount of CC
hero died for Krista fanatics already
here redemption has been picked up by
trick already equalizers available for
expect is gonna get thrown down onto
caps purposes in trouble redemption
already chopped to flash in reckless
they shut down perk support coming in
for on the trick not gonna get knocked
up by the strangle falls and fnatic
delivered so as as well so chaos
everywhere jump back to the river the
fights not done now perks is in from
behind expect burning down reckless and
so as much gets stunned up by my cannon
none of the pack on Ivan's drop quickly
gets hill and reckless gets another
fanatic running circles around g2 back
to the Baron pit this is gonna get messy
scatter the weak doesn't lock anybody
out but the stunned does side step from
perks and is in trouble there's the
equalizer coming down trick burning
reckless is unstoppable picks up another
kill I believe they've run car that's
what price before and I wouldn't have
routes we have two new yes that [ __ ] to
do new Owen is yeah
what that combo is not gonna happen
unfortunately so we're gonna see a
support Alistar in there this time
thorns played he started with and the
politico found the bottom so expect to
see some spamming going out there now
pingers don't clairvoyance on towards I
will dominate you can already see anyway
coming from Moscow 5 it goes to pepper
coming around one side diamonds coming
around the other they are gonna push
towards him they do have smite remember
because they've taken away the blue buff
already oh well diamonds he's gonna go
in he smites in straightaway on towards
I will dominate first blood will be
coming down here gosu pepper look like
he's ready to flash engage here he has
head puts Cara away Manchester gets cuts
out with a poor price scars gonna go
down here that is a quick quick girl
let's go five keeping it real the same
way they have to throw out the
tournament some crazy crazy engages
already ginger was taking pretty low
they have ones to dog once was locus
dear the ulti coming out from carpets or
a good ol tea cake there that will take
down half the damage locust will go down
and that almost certainly will force out
a free dragon they've pushed the waves
out and they are they do know what's
coming up here so parents a half health
nurse you get it immediately jump in I
will dominate he's not in a good place
here boy would go to Protoss house from
CC goes for a half out pops is open as
well scar and now let's go up on they
pick up the one killing Ali since so far
SCARA
get incredibly low head pops now irelia
crushing faces dominate very very low as
well and they have not killed off
Karthus and Karthus he's throwing out so
much damage cutie pie can try to get
away but Qarth assault still available
here and this is looking bad for locusts
now loads blast but alive and he will
come you know sometimes when you play an
off meta champ you can go from looking
like you have 200 IQ to being in bronze
5 sometimes those pocket picks just
don't work out take prompt Italy and to
have a stronger lane against Alistair
a pretty enormous amount most play
champion bhaiyya and shaumyan yeah
if I were flying I'd be careful about
those TiVo hovers man I mean that can
come back to haunt you
this season yeah that was dodgy
yesterday wait what I would imagine
we're going to Game three where's the
team out going fast
that's a next question hi okay it's
going to someday okay all right I guess
that makes the most that makes the most
sense with the lane matchup against the
gnar I think this is some days to do
counter than our baby now it's nap kt
rolster vs jin air three weeks game two
and somehow some way and explicably
painty has accidentally drafted Teemo
can't get over the wall in time he's
gonna get taken out by Trace
yep
boys and trace a little bit not a lot of
damage it was a valiant effort by Katie
probably just should have surrendered
around 20 minutes and then it's gonna be
Nami team oh there he is the little
yodel the little rodent you can see this
yeah little smiles here we go face of
long shoe and we do officially have a
Teemo in lck and it may in fact be the
first ever looks like Cassiopeia will be
locked in gonna be going up against that
Victor in the mid lane which means the
shy will be pardoned with playing this
team on stage a child is once again full
victim to the hard random and we will
get hotter andum top lane Timo from shy
I guarantee giving his champion pool of
Shen and other tanks like trundle he did
not have a room page ready for the Teemo
so at least in the break he had some
time to make team over to mobile fire
you got a pro pill did you look for
Teemo there's nothing there there will
be now he is gonna gonna be the latest
guide on Provos I approved
I no longer know unusually what's
happening before but I really don't know
what's happening maybe this is a
recommended item build I haven't played
do you know in a really long time for
party applause good enough for riots
good enough
here's another amazing Buell that it is
question jumps board triggers the trap
the boomerangs not going to connect but
now here comes crash we're so zoomed in
I couldn't even see arrived and I has to
get out that's not but that is knock off
into the stomach and they will come up
with a kill on doodle doodle wrote in
his first death of the game and probably
the first of many
looks like loves you're gonna be able to
close this one out at thirty three and a
half minutes CJ accidentally drafting
the Teemo condemned them from the start
they just couldn't find a foothold in at
this dependent on how to get teammate
around but now immortal songs' you're
grabbing up karma which has been heavily
contested before actually it was liquid
who played it a whole lot in yesterday's
series when you've actually seen Adrian
played as well with a shield max build
so Lucian plus the Karma grabbed up here
and so that actually bitter just tells
you three of the lanes quark amid Lucian
ad carry karma support with jungle and
top still in the wind right there and we
said we knew where the immortals lanes
are okay but this means we either have a
Corki or Aleutian toppling that's cool
that is that is something we have not
seen in the LCS but it is definitely
something that a models have been
practicing with while turtle does play a
beat Jin so 20 seconds yep they're gonna
swap is swap through alright so you were
right about as far as where the chambers
were going on the lineup the more you
think about it the more it does make
sense of duty then we also see
situations like this where if he was a
tank a level 5 or 6 maokai or poppy he
could have stayed there for the cs and
supportin ad carry at level 4 piece
wouldn't have been enough to threaten
him off but because he's a little
vamp scepter baby Lucien had to back
away don't this quick oh whoa for
nothing well guys that's best up for
this week
now if we missed your favourite off meta
champion pick I care email me at Colin
McNeill that nobody gives up thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]